i'm here okay no problem okay cool
all right hey we're here with matt
wilkides and jeff hodges and they are
launching their uh kickstarter campaign
today
so wait so guys have you launched the
campaign yet or when is it coming it's
going live at midnight tonight oh
so it's gonna be
nine o'clock pacific
wow very cool that's interesting why why
why the midnight release are you gonna
try to create some momentum overnight or
are you guys nighthawks or why midnight
i think it's um the midnight choice i
think was mostly for the end of the
campaign because we are on indiegogo but
it's one of those all or nothing
campaigns though
um
so we're trying to raise 99 000 by
october 5th
and we figure if it ends at midnight
that's going to give the east coast
people the time to keep at it and
pacific coast people will still have uh
good time to generate if we're not
looking like we're gonna hit it that's
good logic yeah i like that and and you
know right off the bat we're gonna talk
about this car we're gonna talk about we
want to hear what you guys have going on
here um because it looks like you guys
have sort of
um you know you've seen sort of the
broken model of distribution and for
independent filmmaking it's something
you want to address and we want to hear
you know what you guys have to say about
it uh right before we do that i'm just
curious
why why indiegogo over kickstarter
especially if you're doing an all or
nothing campaign
yup well one of the reasons why we
decided to do indiegogo is um
we are going to be working with uh
charities for our campaign and that
actually ties in with um in november
we're planning on hosting a film
festival called social change film
festival that's going to be happening in
new orleans so what you could do is if
you couldn't go to new orleans and see
the film festival first hand you could
log on to his cara and watch all the
those different films on our website so
charities have always been something
that matt and i really enjoyed we wanted
to look that into our kickstarter
campaign and get that right into our
company right as we started like right
from the get-go give back to
cool charities that we like and that can
actually have a really cool impact on
the world yeah and kickstarter doesn't
play well with charities at all um in
fact any mention of charities they say
we're out yeah um so we need to switch
platforms over to indiegogo because
we're working with treecycler which is a
great company that gives you codes that
you can
eventually put on their website and plan
a tree somewhere in the world
kiva they deal with micro loans for
entrepreneurs throughout the world um
charity water uh which
drills wells to provide um clean water
to people all over the world and we're
also working with the ithaca motion
picture project um which is here in
ithaca um and they're trying to build a
museum um for the wardens yeah yeah
ithaca has a really rich silent
filmmaking history i guess back in the
1915 uh like the early 1900s like 1915
the wharton brothers had a big studio
where they'd make a bunch of silent
filmmaking pictures here locally in
ithaca so they're trying to build a
museum so when you donate to our
campaign at a certain level we'll toss
them some money too and we're going to
give them a promotion day
we feel like it was really organic to
how so original history yeah and
originally hollywood was in ithaca and
then they moved to los angeles to escape
patents and also because they have
better weather yes a lot better weather
wow so so initially you guys were
looking at kickstarter so that that was
the initial game plan we're doing this
on kickstarter and then you
changed gear to get it over um to
indiegogo is that right
yeah yep and that changeover happened
like two days ago um we had everything
ready to go on kickstarter and then we
ran into problems so we switched but the
cool thing about it is we're still
running the same exact campaign that we
were going to be doing on kickstarter
just on indiegogo so
i don't know it's going to be inherently
the same project that we're going after
and does this have any tie-in with
fractured atlas or or you're getting
actual charities it's not you're making
this a charitable uh contribution
to your campaign
no it's not it's not dealing with um
that partnership um
we're just donating we're just donating
some of the money that we earn in the
perks to charities instead um
because the only i mean we're a film
distributor we only really have t-shirts
to send out or like stickers or
something stuff no one really wants so
instead of um
sending that stuff to people were giving
to other charities um so really your
money goes extraordinarily far with the
ascara indiegogo campaign and also the
cool thing is if people like want
t-shirts and other cool merchandise
stuff we have a digital party planned so
we have different like giveaways or
auctions you can enter in we have a
bunch of talented people who make
posters uh graphic design work um
musical guests that we're gonna have so
if you donate on some of those days
you'd have a chance to win like t-shirts
or leave as cool as cara boxes that have
candy and a t-shirt and everything you'd
want to get your movie experience going
so we we do the kind of fun swag
merchandise stuff
separately from the perks
got it now how long have you been
planning this whole release like when
can you take us back to the first day
that you said you know what we should do
this and and you
ran this idea by each other
well actually that happened way before i
ever knew him actually
yeah
this kara process started about six
years ago um
and
i knew that there are a lot of films
that are really great and it's really
hard to watch them
um so i figured okay that's the problem
and filmmakers are getting paid
so how do we fix this and at that time
that was before hulu existed that was
before netflix instant was around
um so i we were thinking of doing um
streaming film content before anyone
else was really doing it he calls
himself a streaming hipster basically
and uh yeah so we went through like
business model after business model of
the business model had a couple of the
partners that worked with me um we split
ways over different ideologies and for
things not working about a year and a
half ago i leave jeff into this entire
thing and um
we've been working
we've been working for the past year and
a half to get um this car version that
we have today
ready to go and
now is kind of culmination of all of
that work yeah
and so i mean is this a pure passion
project i mean i mean were you guys able
to raise financing to sort of support
yourself for the year and a half and get
yourselves this far is that was there
like a round of investing already and
and now now you're opening it up on
indiegogo um yeah we um we've managed to
stay afloat putting our own money into
it um we've done traditional family
friends um reaching out and that's been
enough to keep us going for a year and a
half but we're kicking it out to
indiegogo because we need help from
other people to keep it going and we
think it'll be something everybody else
wants to be part of we hope at least
yeah we've had about fifteen thousand
dollars invested so far
oh cool
and so in this year and a half time that
you've really sort of hunkered down with
it how much time per day would you say
you're actually spending
on on
perfecting this idea getting ready for
tonight at midnight
uh it depends on the day yeah it's
fluctuated a lot um
i think probably it's heyday we were
putting in like a standard work day i'd
say seven and a half eight hours um
especially because we're watching a lot
of screeners for movies um things we're
trying to keep near to the ground on um
reaching out to sales agents lots of
communication and
other things of that nature i mean it it
it obviously fluctuates but yeah i would
say it's like a standard work day i
would guess
you know i i think it's really timely
that you know here we are connecting you
guys are on the on the on the verge or
the eve or whatever on the brink of of
really of releasing your own campaign to
take yourself to the next level here we
are in our shoes
looking at sort of the distribution
landscape
being frustrated as filmmakers not
necessarily having a lot of options that
that that really are are pleasing to
what we we want to do um and so here we
are
breaking new brown ourselves releasing
the film directly on indiegogo um so so
let's hear more about this idea let's
hear about because you know i'm just
curious how it sort of aligns with some
of the frustrations that we've had and
what you guys are trying to build and
where you guys are trying to go
yeah well i mean our the primary reasons
why we got his car going um
we're not a subscription platform um
we're not looking for all the films that
we can get our hands on um we have very
very strict
um
content standards content yeah we
actually um we told united talent agency
that we weren't interested in one of
their films
um that we watched
so that was kind of a groundbreaking
moment we get the screener from them and
we watch it and we're like we have to
tell these people no aren't we it's
weird and then
yeah it was uh but no it's
it's a big part we don't want to be a
content farm we see lots of
distribution companies just taking
everything and expecting people to watch
all of it as if it was good or worth the
time and money when a lot of times it's
not sometimes i mean it obviously
depends but we want to have this car a
name associated with quality content
that's worth time and money for our
viewers and then even if you get onto a
subscription network or you get onto
netflix
if you get onto netflix because they're
not really interested in independence
anymore um if you get onto hulu or any
of our other competitors you're just one
of a 500 or so um
and i mean how are people going to even
know that you exist so with a smaller
catalog um we can feature films more
prominently we can actually dedicate
um some marketing effort into all the
films that we acquire and what we
acquire it's a non-exclusive contract um
we're all about augmenting releases and
not controlling releases
um because ultimately filmmakers need to
get their work
out there
um
and if it's only i mean we were at um
we were at
tribeca this year and we were looking at
a whole bunch of different um
whole bunch of different films we made
offers on a bunch of them some of them
got sold
um some of them got sold
to
smaller distributors and all of a sudden
that film kind of disappears um we were
in touch with one sales agent okay we
were in touch with one sales agent that
um we wanted to
get their film and they told us that we
don't want to deal with online for one
specialty doc if you're interested in
getting our entire catalog you can have
it like what are we going to do with 150
film
um so it's definitely a very
weird and scary market i think for
independence
to break into
so that's why we kind of decided to go
out there and uh try something new
yeah i mean so so you guys are looking
to be the home for all independence you
guys are looking to find
the the very best independence that you
can
um and attract people to the quality of
films that you're looking to share yeah
i mean a lot of what i've personally
connected with with this car for the
past year and a half i've been involved
with is i mean i'm a huge movie buff i
read and watch movies all the time and
if i'm hearing about a movie that i
really want to see but i can't watch it
right now it's frustrating for me and i
guess that's the thing i've really
connected with wanting to get movies
from film festivals
that are as good as stuff you'd see at
your regular cineplex and get that scene
somewhere and maybe if a lot of people
catch on to that they could go over to a
regal or an amc or something
it's just being able to watch great
content as soon as possible that's the
thing that i've really connected with
most about this
so then i think from watching some of
the videos that you have a part of the
99 000 is going to be toward
building the site i think you said you
had to rebuild it because it's in beta
right now and you weren't sure if it
could support some of this so
who's doing that are the two of you
going to rebuild it or you have a
developer that's coming on board yeah
we're going to be hiring uh outside
developers to uh to go forward with that
we've had our run-ins with um
independent contractors um
we're kind of over the hill with doing
freelance people for the time being
we've had some uh love hate things go on
and that's part of the reason why we um
are looking into
uh redevelopment on the site we do have
a really really strong um
base and that's great but we had some
problems with our last developer um
another story another day but he's no
longer with us you're describing the
world of independent filmmaking
yeah we hear from so many people that
whatever it was you know yeah
yeah it wouldn't be a startup or making
a movie without some of those instances
i mean this is the unfortunate truth
sure
so we have a lot of we have a lot of
high concept um
features that we're going to be adding
in that we've already thought out we've
planned out the logic and how these
things are going to work um we have
recommendation engines that are going to
be super cool and deliver content based
on um your viewing habits and the time
of day um
so we'll be delivering trailers in the
morning when you're watching short form
content we'll be delivering um
stuff for features later on in the
evening um so we have a really great
recommendation engine that we're going
to be rolling out we have a rating
engine and these are just things that we
need um
other larger companies to help us build
out
and of your network whether it be family
and friends or people that you went to
college with are you reaching out
beforehand and letting them know like
this is our idea we plan to launch this
and if so what does your letter say
uh we've we've basically just been
hanging up a lot of our own
local um contacts um i i i've done
acting a lot for the past couple years
and i have a very dedicated actors
workshop and we're sending stuff out to
them
um we have friends who work in local
media like newspapers um radio stations
stuff and that network so really our
local base is covered a lot and we're
also going to be sending out our iskara
boxes to a number of key influencers and
blogs and stuff so
taking a play out of uh the interactive
marketing world yeah
nice okay
you know i'm curious with about some of
the the windows of time um and also sort
of the library the catalog
um
i guess number one
you know you said you're looking to
attract um film sort of off of the film
festival circuit or you know off the
film festival market or or from that
from that world um you know how soon do
you guys want to get these independent
films onto the platform and then once
they're there
you know is it something where once
they're there they stay there or is it
like a window of time where they're
there for like 60 days and they come
down
what's the what's the shape of the
catalog looking like
yeah um right now we have um a really
great selection of short films that we
have from a sales agent um
called short film sales and they've been
great we've also been in contact with
pretty much
a majority of the sales agents that
exist out there a lot of them are
interested but the problem is with
online distribution platforms um
there's a lot of risk associated with it
especially when one of our competitors
pre-screen that did the 60-day
window
um and had 1.1.2 million dollars backing
them uh zeus executives and
groupon executives and
they couldn't make it work um so now
we're trying to sell a platform to sales
agents and they're like well
they had 1.2 million dollars
they didn't work and i mean what were
you guys gonna do
um
so we've been hitting a wall with sales
agents they've people are interested
they're waiting on us to be operational
so
during the campaign we're going to be
working on extending our catalog
substantially um we hitting up all the
sales agents that we've been in contact
with and um sorry in the review process
yet again but in terms of uh how long
the movie will stay on our platform we
work hand in hand with our filmmakers on
a time they feel would be
most reasonable for them to stay on our
platform um we can extend it to however
little or however much they want it to
be on and it's always flexible if they
get picked up by another distribution
company because we're doing all
exclusives so we're saying you know
we're more than welcome to go ahead and
go with a bigger company the only thing
is we just remove it from the sales
floor and the people who would purchase
that movie would still be able to watch
it
just no more future sales yeah
well that was it's funny because you
must been reading my mind i was about to
bring up free screen and and they had
beautiful movies on there and one
that there was some up in the air about
was the eight dollar price point after a
certain amount of time do you have a
designated price point or will it vary
for
various movies shorts versus features
we do have a different price point for
our shirts shorts versus our features um
it also depends um on our rental versus
a purchase um we're gonna be rolling out
a rental service in conjunction with
purchases right now our rentals are
gonna hover somewhere between um six
seven dollars for a feature somewhere
like uh we use a kind of like a
barometer of like a movie ticket for
like a rental and then when you purchase
it it would be a little bit higher than
the movie ticket but a little bit less
than the dvd
got it okay because again essentially we
want to have that like dvd collection
type thing
in the cloud
is what we're going for
and and will that price be sort of fixed
or because with uh pre-screen i think it
was you know the first whatever few days
you could get it for less and then once
that point was gone it was then eight
dollars
um the only time that we're gonna be
fluctuating prices is during some of our
daily deals like um
steam the
gaming clients um they have daily deals
all the time they do different sales
the one thing that we do have in our
contracts is the ability to change
pricing at any time um so we could just
roll out a deal to see if we could bump
sales for somebody um
yeah i got like on low traffic days like
not tuesday or wednesday or something we
could have a deal for a film and try to
get more traffic generated to that one
or
push our short films a little bit more
it's really flexible it's actually
pretty cool
and do you have any projections in terms
of how large the library will grow i
mean is it something you where you want
to keep it down because you said you
don't want to say take everything but
you know how much content are our you
know users gonna when they come to the
site how much content can we expect to
find well it uh it pretty much depends
um we're gonna keep building our catalog
with as many great films we could find
um and we've been kind of toying with an
idea of trying to figure out an
end-to-end solution for
um filmmakers to help monetize their
films using our players and our pay
walls so that they can um it won't be a
part of the
main is kara collection the curated
collection but we are kind of toying
with an idea of eventually rolling out
an enzyme solution for full maker such
yourself to do
um self distribution i know all the
platforms like dynamo exist and stuff
but
with our content providers we're using
some of the best online delivery
networks that exist um akamai is our
biggest
um content delivery network uyla does
all of our
video transcoding so each film is
transcoded
seven times right now we're gonna be
bumping that up to about nine ten times
as we start rolling out more high
definition stuff um we're so you're
really not going to find a better player
or a better um solution but we're still
trying to figure out the logistics
behind an end-to-end solution but it's
something that we're definitely
considering and during our kickstart
during our sorry indiegogo campaign um
we will be interested in hearing from
other filmmakers on like what you're
what they're looking for with an
end-to-end solution because we do want
to make a process easier and there
should be
i mean self-distribution is kind of hard
because you have it on your website but
then it's your website you need to push
people to your website and
with this car we're trying to make a
centralized location for people to go to
see really great content and to be able
to access a lot of stuff um
so it becomes that centralized hub that
people can go to to find additional
content instead of people starting to um
embed streams on their own sites if we
do roll out of an end to end solution
you will be able to embed wherever you
want but i mean that's still on the
burner for a couple months down the line
you know i hate i hate to ask the
question but i feel like i have to um
you know looking at looking at
pre-screen you know looking at that that
um they had to sort of close down their
doors for now they've kind of left it
open but we don't know if it's going to
come back or not when you guys look at
pre-screen and look at the resources
that they had available to them and them
not being able to make it work um
where did they go wrong in your eyes
and what are you guys doing
that that gives you confidence moving
forward with this car
i think the main thing with free screen
was kind of like a content farm thing
that we were talking about earlier i
mean if you are wanting to build a
successful distribution company um
i guess i would liken it to something um
like recently film district is a is a
company that i've associated with really
cool movies that have been released
lately we did like drive like rum diary
they're doing looper this month in
september it's associating that name
with that quality content so when you
see like is kara or our name then you're
gonna be like oh like i know i'm gonna
get something at least really intriguing
yeah and um and they're all i think they
had some design stuff that was a little
like left a little bit to be desired and
also their um their updates for letting
you know about movies is something that
yes yeah the only the only way yeah
that's what exactly yes
um they did the they did a very similar
idea to groupon where they send you a
new film every day but then they started
running out of films so he started
sending you trailers for films that he
didn't have
so now you're watching film or trailers
for films that are in theaters and will
never be on free screen because when we
saw the um
actually it was right around sundance
time i think um they started being like
oh yeah these are all the sundance films
we're like how this how the hell did the
priesthood get all the sundays and then
you go on it's like oh they have the
trailers for the sundance movies
yeah so they were trying to do that
daily deal thing um
it was going to my spam inbox um
they had a lot of trailers not a lot of
films
um
and then ultimately
i'm just gonna come out and say it like
some of the titles
weren't really that great um we watched
a lot of screeners
um
after a pre-screen went away and there
were very few of them that we were
really interested in or even comfortable
having on our service yeah so it was
definitely one of those things where
do you have content that people want to
buy um do you have content that you feel
comfortable
selling to people and that's a very
that's a very serious question for us um
and one that
we're always going to be
um
what's what i'm looking for
that it's just a concept that we're
really always going to
embrace
like when we look at each film can we
sell this
and it does when we say can we sell this
we're not talking about does it have
name actors or is it a four quadrant
film
um because those are the big hollywood
movies and we're not interested in that
there are a bunch of people that want
new unique
interesting content and it's really hard
to find that um so for us when it comes
down to can we sell this it's more of a
is a shot well
is the sound good like is the story
interesting um are you avoiding a lot of
the independent uh cliches um because i
think unfortunately the were the world
independent film has kind of gotten a
negative connotation when you inject
independent because
i mean they're 50 000 films produced
each year how many of those are actually
worth watching
um
so we're trying to definitely change the
thought process behind independent
releases
um to get people
looking at it like oh you know what
because this was produced outside of the
studio system
it's going to have a story they haven't
seen before and it's going to be
it's a good film it just doesn't have
the name afterwards
so we're trying to fill in that
uh left that area
yeah i
you know i tell you you know i think i
think you guys are in for a good fight
you know
you know and basically our perspective
is
is with karen and i you know we hosted
us you know we're not just filmmakers we
don't just do film courage we don't just
um you know all that stuff you know we
also spent two years um distributing
films we hosted a monthly screening
series here in los angeles
and and one of the troubles we found
ourselves in
is you know certainly we can all
identify films that are moving that
affect us that that are wonderful that
that that have all those things we want
you know
um and we found from our shoes it's
really hard to get access to those films
um because they're already tied up sort
of with their own distribution path you
know so it's like it's one thing to say
like we're gonna have great content and
identify it and say yeah this is it
that's what we want to have
it's a whole other animal to actually
you know have them trust in you
and in our case like want to scream with
us they're you know we we we we weren't
in a position where we could get sort of
the sundance films we wanted or these
other like films would be like yeah it'd
be great to screen this and show this
but there's a lot of films that that
were like damn we wish we could do it
and it got to be really frustrating on
our end because there were certain films
that we wanted the screen and we
couldn't get at they just there's just
no way it's going to happen um
they're not going to screen at like some
monthly screening series when they have
a chance at sundance and they have a
chance to build other things and so you
guys are getting ready to fight the same
battle you guys are going to be fighting
off netflix and itunes and all these
reputable platforms and that's the fight
you guys have to put in
how do you guys respond to what i'm
saying here
i
i guess i would respond by saying that i
hope people would latch on to our
passion enthusiasm and just the fact
that we've gotten this far
ourselves as essentially recent college
graduates on fifteen thousand dollars
that we've spent
and we're still pushing forward i mean
one of the things we always talk about
internally is all the stuff that's
happened good and bad internally with us
is we've always persevered and pushed on
and it's because inherently matt and i
love film and we love movie making and
we want to get these things seen
and i think
it's just a matter of time until
filmmakers or sales agents and audiences
catch on to the fact
that we have that passion and i think
it's something that's kind of like an x
factor i think in anything in life
whether you're doing a business or
you're just going on your day-to-day i
think there's that inherent factor with
passion and the love for movies and we
have and we've definitely tried to
streamline the entire process um i mean
you could go from
making an account to getting a high
definition stream
in less than 30 seconds and that stream
is already mobile optimized um when you
buy the content it's yours forever um
it's not just one of those one-off deals
we're really trying to make the
experience as cool as we possibly can
make it
and we've been fighting sales agents um
we were in negotiation for a film for
about six months
um
and then they were like okay we sent
over to contracts they were like this
looks great you can't have north america
it's like what do you mean we were
discussing this from the very beginning
when we started searching you we started
going for your film when it was in
sundance
and now you're telling us that you can't
sell it in north america and we're a
north american distributor
like you wasted six months of our time
um and then there are a lot of other
agents that just
aren't interested in selling their
clients
films um yeah so it's just it's
definitely something that we're going to
be
fighting for a while until we
get to the where we are an actual
legitimate distributor yeah i think i
think it's uh the passion tied up with a
lot of the technical stuff we're putting
into we have a lot of good ideas that
are built upon our love for filmmaking
i'm wondering too how do you plan to get
people to go to your site because you
said you don't want it to be where
there's an embeddable player for these
filmmakers you want to have them come to
your site what are you planning to do to
draw traffic to your site
we actually um the only reason why we
don't have embeddable players is because
it's hard for
a paywall solution to follow that in bed
and then it's also hard to
make sure that embed is safe
because piracy is
an issue
and it's an issue that sales agents have
like okay you're online how is it going
to be safe well we have each stream that
we have is encrypted um
a big thing that we've been saying to
sales agents is we have we do have
digital rights management and it's very
restrictive but very transparent it's
kind of the same way that um
steam is organized and that's the place
that you can go and buy a video game
um plan on your computer and then if you
have another computer as long as you
have that steam account linkedin you can
watch it on that computer too or play it
on that computer as well
and everyone says oh this is great
because there's no drm but there's all
the drm you can't be off of that
platform and watch the film so it's
really safe for the um
it's safer to and distributors it's safe
for the publishers
and it's a great experience for the end
user um which is something that we're
definitely
um going for too and i do have a lot of
friends that work in marketing that i
have been helping us out um i was
interning at warner brothers in their
interactive marketing department for a
while back in uh 2010 so i've seen how
the hollywood pictures do it um so we
have a bunch of ideas of our own um that
we'll be rolling out we actually have a
marketing budget to play with so let's
run off oops
yeah our lights are motion centered here
let me oh i see okay yeah they're on
most consensus so they'll turn back on
there we go
i like that but yeah yeah we have lots
of uh cool marketing pr stuff leave a
line enough like the interactive
marketing i was talking about obviously
being on indiegogo will be a great way
to get people
um we are working with uh we sign up
with vocus locus is going to be a good
thing for us to use in terms of having
special immediate pr releases out yeah
sorry we just watched a cat try to scale
a wall and then he fell oh
that's okay
yeah so in terms of the campaign itself
it's how many days
ends october 5th so it's going so 35 i
think 35 ish i think it's 35 yeah we
counted it through there we know it goes
from tonight at midnight to october 5th
so it's like a friday to friday
basically
okay and then do you have a game plan in
terms of what you're going to do every
day do you have oh yeah yep okay yeah
we're spending a long time organizing
the calendar um making sure we have uh
like either hangouts or talks or
releasing a video or having a live
performance doing a giveaway an auction
we've got a lot of fun stuff planned so
we hope people will
donate and get to check it out because
it's gonna be fun
you know i want to come back to to sort
of um you know if you guys i know you
guys have a short window of time here
and so you know we still have a lot of
questions but if you guys we're just
going to another screening
um it's so it's it's just like an
outdoor fun function where they're
screening a silent film yeah we're
probably going to be late to it anyway
so we got as much time yeah yeah it's
our it's our uh the ithaca motion
picture project is doing an outdoor
screening silent films tonight so we're
gonna go and support them there it's
gonna be really cool
oh are you gonna announce the
information about the campaign
yeah yeah we're uh we're bringing
business cards with us um we're going to
be talking with some of the people there
and letting them know about the
partnership so that'll be a fun fun
event for everyone oh very cool yeah so
yeah while we have you i i would just
like to hear if you guys can maybe
highlight some more
some more of the benefits for filmmakers
because i know you guys you know part
part of what you guys believe in is is
putting filmmakers first and and
treating them right i believe part of
the
part of what you guys are doing is is um
you know as the you know you guys don't
take any money up front as as money
comes in than the money goes to the
filmmaker can you talk just more and
more about the benefits you guys um have
going for filmmakers
yeah i think it's a the fair revenue
splits that we have and we can do that
because we're a pay-per-view model as
opposed to subscription based so
filmmakers get paid what they're
actually getting for views as opposed to
something like netflix we get like a 3
000 deal to be in there for a year and
it doesn't matter if one person watches
it or 10 million people watch it they
still get that 3 000 so we think it's
fair for the filmmaker to get their cut
of however many views they get and here
our revenue splits are in line with um
our industry partners uh for rentals
it's 70 30. same thing that is
that all the rest of the platforms have
um but the one thing that kind of sets
up all right sorry man um they entered
the connection
as you were given the numbers so it's
not like you were getting ready to say
70 is that right yep 70 30 leaning
filmmaker um
and the really cool part about that is
we don't have any upfront fees um
we actually pay
sometimes if necessary to get the
copy of the film to us
um but the filmmaker doesn't actually
get any uh they're not charged for
anything
so we stand to lose money on some of the
films that we acquire but the way that
we have our system set up um we can
either do it the traditional route which
some of our sales agents like better for
some reason where we have all of the
line items that are taken out from um
from the
top sale so
if we've spent um
let's say i don't know two thousand
dollars marketing your film doing all
the transcode doing delivery all that
stuff
then your film needs to sell two
thousand dollars worth of sales before
you start making money but one of the
systems that we have is we take off a
percentage from the top from each sale
and that's
um generally between like 15 20
so filmmakers are getting money from
sale number one and we are we are
recouping our expenses as people are
buying um so it kind of works out really
well for us really well for our content
providers
and we think that's going to be a really
cool new system
to do distribution so now you don't have
to see that really complicated earnings
report where your film is going to lose
money um and it's guaranteed your film
is going to lose money so now you're
actually making money from cell number
one
i mean so just to further clarify so
that means from sale number one um
you're not necessarily getting the
filmmaker's not getting 70 total i guess
off the first sale like maybe they're
getting whatever 55 percent and then
over time then it works itself back to
70 pages basically what happens is um
if the filmmaker has their film
um
twenty percent is taken off the top of
that sale price so it's five dollars we
take twenty percent to cover our line
items and then from there it's 70 30. so
it's a 70 30 net deal um not a gross
deal and that way the filmmaker gets
paid their share of that um of that 70
after expenses have been covered and
then we take what's left um
and that means this filmmaker is
actually walking away having made money
on their first sale
thank you for being so transparent with
what you guys have you know the
percentage i mean you know that's great
to hear you know sometimes i know with
free screen it was it was a little
harder to get at the numbers you had to
really get into the fine print to get an
understanding of just like what what are
the deals um yeah so no that that's
great to hear and and and i know um
i i know a lot of people are going to
wonder since this is a platform you're
building and obviously you guys are
looking to put great content on there um
what are some of the additional things
that you guys are doing in terms of
marketing in terms of promotion um
that's going to draw interest um you
know how are you guys marketing um the
platform as well as the films
it's going it's a multi-tiered strategy
um obviously the indiegogo campaign as
much as we need for funding it's also to
get this car name out there into the
community um
and then from there we're going to start
doing
um ad buys for each individual title um
depending on
depending on who that title might be
applicable to um so we're going to be
doing on a per title level as well as a
platform level um marketing but really
what we're thinking of doing is just
marketing each title individually
because that's what's going to drive the
traffic to us initially not our name
it's going to be our content
and the other cool thing is if the
filmmakers are willing we
more than want to put them front and
center and say you know this is your
movie you made this i mean when i watch
a movie i kind of consider it as like a
point of view thing i'm watching someone
else's point of view into your life
experience so i i think a lot of film
people would like to be like okay who's
the director of this movie who made this
why did they make it um we were more
than willing to work with our directors
and filmmakers to you know feature them
give them interviews um provide special
features in conjunction with the movie
so after you watch it you can watch an
interview with them in the cast and like
okay you know what were some of the hard
things that you experienced making this
movie or what was your intention behind
this um
so working and actually getting a
relationship built internally with our
filmmakers i think would be a great
attraction for film lovers which i think
you know i i i guess i always use myself
as a standard because i mean if you look
over here off screen i have a huge shelf
of dvds um and i think and they're like
i watch special features commentaries so
i want to have that built into our car
experience also
yeah
i you know what i like about talking to
you guys um you know over the past
however long it's been
um you know i i like that it sounds like
you guys have some fight and you guys
you know i i like hearing your passion
and and i like hearing because you don't
actually hear a lot of platforms say
like look we're going to put in the
fight with you
so i i i think that that's just really
um it's really nice to hear yeah and i
like the fact that you have planned it
out and you have thought about a lot of
different details and it's not just
uh you know just sounds like a great
idea and not thinking it through and i'm
sorry did you say before why you were
doing the all or nothing version of
indiegogo did i miss that
oh yeah well we're doing all or nothing
for 99 000. because that's really what
we need to keep going i mean anything
less would be
cheapening the experience for our users
um it's more it's having a necessity
um and so we we want to
because we've heard of other campaigns
going for smaller amounts and then going
to another campaign and people are like
well wait we just gave you fifty
thousand dollars why do you need another
forty um so we wanna do the all or
nothing make it what it is acknowledge
that we're in that position and we hope
people will
respond to that and we think we think
they can
and will
does your fight does your fight end
if the campaign comes up short
no we we have uh lots of other plans for
cool things um we that's always
something matt and i have talked about
um we have really interesting plans for
i mean we're not gonna divulge
everything right now but we do have
other methods we can go um it's it's
it's very valuable
and i mean we're hosting social change
film festival in november regardless of
what happens um there were their primary
technical sponsor we're super excited to
be working with them
um and we think we're going i mean we're
going to be hosting their festival come
november whether we make that funding
goal or not yep um
so if we don't hit our indiegogo mark it
might tell us that hey you know what
filmmakers and audience people aren't
really interested in a platform where
they can watch
independent titles and then we go back
to the drawing board and try and figure
something else out um
because at iskara we have something that
we're really proud of called this cara
apps which is kind of like uh google's
version of the 20 of your work time you
can do whatever the hell you want um so
our employees can just think of really
cool stuff and if we all like it
internally we build it and whether
that's a social network or a cool mobile
app we're still working on stuff so
we're going to have something regardless
of whether we make our funding or not
but
if you want the is cara experience that
is carl platform for video video rental
we're going to need to hit that mark yep
and and taking time into consideration
here i mean do you guys have any
questions for us i mean i know you guys
have been monitoring our release on
indiegogo goodbye promise um
you know so
yeah yeah we just got our copy today and
once we get past the initial indiegogo
hubbub of starting it up we're
definitely gonna give it a watch so
we're excited oh yeah yeah no i know you
guys have a lot on your plate right now
yeah yeah
just for you to like watch the film
before you release yeah yeah no
uh so what brought you to indiegogo why
didn't you
uh what was wrong with the distributors
out there
you know from from our our perspective
um you know we have a small film that
that um
you know i mean obviously we have we
have limited resources we've had limited
money um all along you know so so this
is a small film um that we that we shot
with no money and that we we crowdfunded
to cover a lot of the post-production
expenses but even with that you there's
still money that you should have to put
in from your own pocket um to get it all
the way done and there's still even some
stuff now even though it's released and
people are watching it there's still
some stuff that we'd love to be able to
fix but it just gets to a point where
you just
you just don't have the time the money
that you know and you just have to say
okay this is what we have and so let's
go with it so um there's certainly that
um and as you know we and this is not
our first film this is our second
feature and so
you know the thing that was frustrating
for us is is taking um our first film
two film festivals and we did a bunch of
one-off screenings in different cities
and it's like we put all this energy
promoting it
and and it just got to a point where as
people were learning of the film and
wanted to share it it just wasn't
available um so you know
we started getting our heads like you
know when we get around
to releasing goodbye promise you know we
just we just like to just have it so
that is instantly instantly available um
for anybody really you know and so we
started thinking about like how could we
make it available to everybody in the
world
all at once um you know is there a way
that people can just instantly access it
so that if they do like it they'll be in
a position to share it um then you also
look at you know that's sort of some
thinking there some other thinking is
like
so much um promotion and excitement and
fun is happening
on the funding side of things you know
you guys have already alluded to it that
you're not just going after money with
um with your release on indiegogo you're
also looking forward to to sort of get
your name out there and put you in a
position to do press to talk about what
you're doing talk about your idea and
maybe attract as many believers to your
platform as possible um so funding has
that now
and and somehow in the distribution
process it's lost it's like it's not
really exciting to to
to come across independent films
um or i don't know
there's not the same excitement exists
you know yeah you can watch on itunes
you can watch on netflix you can watch
on dod it it doesn't have that same
exciting component that crowdfunding has
so
um
you know so we just we're looking at
that um you know and we don't
necessarily want to release it directly
on our own website because it's really
hard to drive traffic
you know somewhere on the internet it's
really difficult
we wanted to be on a platform where
people where that was already an
existing discovery platform that had
eyeballs and sort of
you know hopefully you know
that doesn't mean that we're getting a
lot but we wanted to get some of those
eyeballs onto our film that way yeah and
not only that if we did get a
traditional distribution deal and we
need like arizona mission insurance and
all these different things it would just
put us more sort of in the hole and and
we pretty much spent you know
you know we had extra costs outside of
the crowdfunding but luckily it's not
substantial so it's just like this is
more of an easier way
to kind of guarantee that somebody sees
it and then actually be more in the
black instead of the red you know
yeah
it's actually kind of funny that um you
guys are mentioning that there's
so much excitement on crowdfunding and
the entire community comes together when
somebody's like hey we're at the last
couple of minutes i really want to make
this project but when the project
finally comes out yeah it doesn't seem
like many people care anymore
and
it's like now we've built the products
we've got the money we've done
everything now it's ready to be watched
and i
i don't have an answer
to why that occurs yeah um because it's
as perplexing to us as it is for you
guys
yeah you know that's where you know we
believe in the power of the scoreboard
essentially you know what what
crowdfunding has is it has that
transparency and so
you know what we've seen for years now
you know there's just sort of like you
know like just as a regular sort of
movie fan movie go where it's like you
go to the film's website you go there
once you see the trailer you see the
website oh this is cool um you know you
look through the casting crew and maybe
they have some extras there
and then you leave and really there's no
reason to return back to that website
like why go back to the film's website
you know and so well the content doesn't
usually change yeah it's gonna it's
gonna be exactly the same unless the
filmmaker has a blog or they're talking
about their experience or something yeah
so you know it's gonna be the same
content yeah yeah there's nothing there
you know and what crowdfunding has is it
has you know if you can gain momentum
and if you can put the work in and if
you can sort of move that needle forward
you have this the ticking the ticking
clock on one hand that's going down and
down and down and then you have sort of
this this other number this funding goal
that hopefully is going up and up and up
so
it's like if you can get to a point
where people check in with you it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you
have one dollar whatever if you can just
start getting people on board and people
see the scoreboard
and then they go away and then if they
come back and if that number has gone up
in your favor and that time is going
down it just starts to get emotional you
know so now you start to get this
emotional investment from the audience
and um yeah it's just exciting you know
it's just much more exciting and right
now that's lacking in the world of
distribution you know there's nothing
you know so it's like distribution is
going to have to change and it's going
to have to start using
um some some of these kind of techniques
um of transparency
to really push it to the next level
because right now it lacks transparency
people don't want to be straightforward
about what the numbers are and so me as
an audience member i can't get invested
in it you know there's nothing it's just
like yeah i get to watch a movie well i
have i have a billion movies i can watch
right now you know there's nothing
exciting about it yeah and i think you
know you were saying that's a really
good point about you know how once the
movie actually comes out there's kind of
this ho-hum response and it is an
interesting sort of look i mean it's
similar to like an ipo when it comes out
everyone's like oh what's it at now you
know the first day it opened
the opening bell rings and everyone's so
excited but then you know and and it's
the thing where we all want to be part
of this process and watch it kind of go
up and up and up but you're right then
once it's done and it is a fascinating
thing uh
and i think people kind of live
vicariously through somebody else's
campaign and think oh wow how cool now
they get to do this they get to live
this sort of dream and and
it is an interesting fact but
yeah i i think that's great and it sort
of triggers this other idea i mean you
know we just got off the line with
another filmmaker blaine weaver and he
talked about you know he loves the
theatrical experience because he loves
experiencing it with people you know
where there's like this direct
connection
and that's another thing we don't see in
distribution is we don't see the social
component of it you know and something
that you get on a platform like
indiegogo is you can see that other
people are getting behind this film you
know there's the transparency of like oh
this many people are supporting this you
know what i'm saying so it's just like
that that's a social component that
makes it more exciting that you're not
alone that you're not the only one that
supports this and so
that's where we believe so strongly in
the power of transparency and you know i
don't know if what we're saying i don't
know if that somehow translates or you
know you guys can because we don't
necessarily want to build a platform you
know but if
if we can share some ideas with guys
like you that have the passion that do
want to build a platform
this is what
people yeah well i think there's a lot
of carryover i mean one of the things
matt and i have always talked about is
filmmaking inherently is a very
communal thing i mean when you make a
movie you're asking favors from friends
families
um lots of people i mean starting a
business is very much the same i mean
how look at the four of a kind yeah um
thing that was
my i've never seen my twitter account
that active yeah and the cool thing that
i think crowdfunding allows for is the
same thing that filmmaking is it's an
inherently communal thing where you are
working with not just yourself but other
people and um one of the things we're
wanting to see and i'm i've actually i
would be interested to see your thoughts
on this is
we're wanting to have more of an open
relationship between distribution
companies and filmmakers
um
where would you guys stand on that
i i just think it's a logistics issue
you know like when i immediately hear
the idea i just you know because you
know at this point in time you guys are
really small team
and so depending on how many films
you're able to sort of bring into the
library into the catalog it's just going
to get to a point where you only have so
much time you can allocate um to each
individual film and each you know you
know we we certainly know from the
number of independent filmmakers we've
we've spoken to over the years that you
know we all have our own ego you know
and we especially have our ego when it
comes to our work so i think navigating
that is it's really
it's its own job and it's a sort of
logistics thing i think it's it's you
know
i think it's a wonderful idea to have
it maybe you know that yeah some quick
thoughts there well i mean we're
definitely trying to make um
we're definitely trying to make
distribution fun yes um and that's
actually part of the reason why we're
doing this crowdfunding thing because we
could have gone to venture capitalists
um i know a lot of people who are well
connected in
silicon valley and
i know people with money but do we want
to have
a board to answer to or do we want our
shareholders and our stakeholders to be
our audience and our filmmakers because
then we can do whatever we want
um and a part of the indiegogo campaign
we do want to start conversations like
what
what does it take
to get people interested now in watching
films um what does it take to start that
conversation to start people sharing to
be like hey check out this really
awesome film um like with goodbye
promise you guys are on indiegogo and
it
i've haven't seen as much activity as i
would
like to see from
all of the filmmakers that i follow on
twitter i mean in my opinion it's really
awesome
that i mean frankly you guys are doing
something that is truly revolutionary
and i think that is going to be
something that will be
copied and people are going to start
looking to release films that way and we
have this really revolutionary system
now that you guys are doing and the
conversation around that isn't really
what i think anybody was expecting it's
not as prolific as i think anyone wants
it to be um and it's just one of those
questions on how do we
fix that system how do we get people
involved how do we get people engaged
with the final product as opposed to
trying to raise money for a product sure
yeah well i mean you know it's great i
love it i love it you know i think you
know when indiegogo and kickstarter
started on the funding side of things
when they started as crowdfunding
platforms you know it's taken them a
while to to sort of build up steam you
know to build up the user base
um you know and honestly i think i think
we'd have a lot more success right you
know currently in terms of the number of
people i think we would have had a
higher number to date um
had we gone on on kickstarter you know
but at the same time we didn't want this
we didn't want the risk to be so great
where it's literally all or nothing um
you know so we didn't want that um so
um and and and honestly kickstarter is
just a superior platform over indiegogo
you know indiegogo um you know they're
gonna they're they've been great to us
and they're like they're giving us this
opportunity and we can we can sing their
praises for days we still believe this
is the best platform at least for us
that exists and we have no regrets about
the decision whatsoever but they're
gonna have to grow as a platform
um in a lot of ways not just not just
for what we're doing but just in general
there's just a lot of things that that
they need to get up to speed on that
it's not there yet so i think we're hurt
by that in our case also we took a week
off of our own campaign you mentioned
jack marchetti um we just really believe
in his story we believe in that that of
him making his film and so we took a
week off of our own efforts to try to
get behind that and try to push it as
far as we could and um you know
obviously you guys seeing that you know
we had an impact we didn't get all the
way there but we had an impact but i
think it's interesting that you guys
bring that up then we we weren't sure in
the beginning how it was going to be
perceived and i think it's a couple
things i think uh people are kind of
watching and and waiting and seeing you
know and also too some people might like
you said want to jump on and do it
themselves so i it's an interesting
thing i i can't explain it either but uh
we've just got to keep going and like i
said it's almost a social experiment
that's why it's my new word for the it's
a social experiment but in some sense it
is you know and if we fail at it fine i
mean do we expect to raise a million
dollars no um but uh that's why we went
also with indiegogo knowing that it
would be it would never get to that
point yeah yeah you know it's
you know we realized the risk at stake
you know and this and you know this is
breaking new ground um and we just felt
like someone was going to do it sooner
or later we decided you know you know
we're willing to take that risk we're
willing to sort of dive out into the
abyss and just and just let it go and
put our own effort behind it you know
and so um you know we're excited to do
that we're excited for the opportunity
uh we believe um it is heading this way
um i think it you know we think it's a
great way for small films that maybe
will you know get a lot of closed doors
you know going other traditional ways we
think this is a new sort of freeing way
to do it uh but it's brand new so we
have to kind of like
you know there's so much more legwork
that we have to put into it and
hopefully to get to a point if if more
people do this sort of thing and it'll
it'll evolve and it'll become something
people become more familiar with and
you'll see people rally earlier um
you know that yeah and somebody with a
much bigger uh audience would probably
do a an incredible job
with little
little money online except for what they
would owe to indiegogo so yeah
yeah yeah i mean you guys asked pretty
much from the sounds of it accidentally
did one of those hey what you want
um things that um uh humble indie bundle
yes does for um video games and they
just got into trying it out for music
too
um where they would collect a bunch of
things and you could pay what you want
um whether it's a penny or
couple thousand dollars people have done
um so i think you guys kind of
accidentally stumbled on to pay what you
want system for
film which to
my knowledge hasn't really been done
before
you know
you know you know really you know a lot
of the idea um was sort of in my head
and then and then as i began to share it
with karen we just sort of went back and
forth in terms of what it should be i
was really insistent on having a dollar
price point to offer the film at that
level um and i was pretty much fine with
that you know karen really pushed for a
higher um pay scale and so you know what
you see in terms when you go to our
campaign you see we have the the one
dollar the first 100 people that are
sort of the so-called early birds get it
for a dollar and then the two dollar
standard contribution that that's just
basically karen and i going back and
forth
and um you know we certainly did not
expect um you know we did not expect the
the higher contribution level you know
so you know we thought maybe we could
get around 1500 the way we are right now
we thought we'd be there but we thought
we'd have 1500 people to go with it you
know we didn't think that we'd have you
know whatever it is 200 and something
people and then the dollar amount we are
not it's really been a you know it's
been a really pleasant surprise
yeah it's been really nice
that's definitely awesome yeah
definitely wish uh we're definitely
gonna be pushing you guys as well um
when you are finishing up your campaign
and um i really truly believe that you
guys are doing something that
um is going to be
revolutionary i mean
the direct to consumer
sales is going to be something that i
think is really going to start taking
off and
we're really lucky to be living at a
time where
we're on the cusp now of something that
is
similar to
hollywood films going from silent era
movie making to talkies yeah the online
era is going to be something
revolutionary and it's just a matter of
time because we all know how it's going
to work and it's just people like you
that
are
are trying new systems and it might not
work for others but people are trying
new things and that's a really awesome
that's a really awesome something's
going to stick just a matter of time oh
thank you oh thank you matt thanks jeff
um you know yeah i mean if you look at
it this is where the studios are trying
to get to you know they're trying to get
to a point where you know after their
theatrical run
you know or maybe even like during the
theatrical run they they want to
immediately be everywhere but it's
because of the the the ongoing struggle
they have with the theater chains that
they're not able to do that and maybe
some of the other platforms just some of
the way they have to roll out their film
in a certain way but you know we as
independents we as small films we don't
have to play by those rules
you know a lot of filmmakers still do a
lot of filmmakers still look at it that
traditional way
we just knew our our best our best path
was just try to be quick try to be agile
just go right to the people do it now
while we can and just and just put our
heart our passion our work into it and
just see what happens so um you know we
still have 12 days left
12 days left to push this all the way
and
see all day is a lot of time yes
it's true it's very true
so
awesome you know i think we know you
guys have to get i mean is it started
already this is the screening yeah it
looks like yeah
knowing like i know
it will be good it's all it's all okay
all right sure drive
okay no we we thank you guys yeah we
thank you guys so we're wishing you
guys thank you guys for having us really
means a lot so so then you're gonna come
back and then you're gonna launch the
campaign is that right so you're ready
yep to go
come back and launch this thing at
midnight and uh pop open a bottle of
wine yes
celebrate it
see what happens yeah
are you guys gonna film it just as the
launching of just just
in case whatever happens and and you
need
archival footage and
let's do it you know what might as well
we have cameras we have computers
we never thought of it actually no we're
going to we're going to take that
actually hopefully you're cool with us
taking your idea okay
and once you guys have it we'll we'll
embed the video underneath um this uh
you know interview once we put it on our
site so
sick all right guys and good luck
tonight yeah get ready for the good
fight
thank you very much thank you so much
good luck guys
we'll see you we'll see you on twitter
appreciate it okay yeah take care take
it easy